time of the month again looking for a
way to hide your used menstrual products
no well neither were thousands of women
who watched these guys launch their
solution to one of women's unsolved
problems
according to them the two friends went
on a tv show to request funding for
their game-changing invention
pinky gloves reversible plastic gloves
pink ones of course
that can be used to discreetly dispose
of bloody tampons and pads wherever
you are the idea came to them while
sharing an apartment with women
smelly and visible tampons and the
bathroom bin
they called it unpleasant and described
being
amazed they did win funding because
what's not to like well a lot actually
the founders were immediately accused
of period shaming the stigmatization of
people
for menstruating it frames menstruation
as something that
we should be hiding it frames it as
something
unhygienic as something dirty or even a
problem that should be
yeah made as invisible as possible
there's still this
ideal of uh or this this picture of a
woman that
doesn't have any body functions and it
is perfectly
hiding everything it always just smells
like flowers
and i think it's it's so ridiculous and
sad that this is
still existing in mainstream society so
this product would even
have this yeah have this stage and find
investors
and that is problematic the
stigmatization of menstrual processes
leads to a lack of discussion
about issues that affect half of the
world's population
like the discrimination or exclusion of
people who menstruate
or period poverty over a lifetime those
of us who menstruate will have to spend
an
average of 20 000 euros on menstrual
hygiene products
and that is a cost some 500 million
people
just cannot afford and that can have
devastating effects on their health
and their social participation so it's
not like there aren't any period related
problems that could be
tackled most menstrual hygiene products
for example are
extremely bad for the environment every
year
200 000 tons of this kind of menstrual
waste end up on our landfills
but hey if you wrap it in a pink plastic
glove
at least it looks cute after pinky gate
took
off the two founders attempted damage
control of crime fire what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't like the idea that they believe
that they have
started now this kind of discussion
because
this also silences a lot of menstrual
activism that has been going on for
decades and even especially in the
last couple of years worldwide there's a
growing
movement of menstrual activism and
people who are
actually working in education and new
laws
and they are promoting um free sanitary
products for everyone who need it so i
think they should really reflect on that
and support these movements like the
female led
startup oh yeah they participated in the
same show two years ago seeking funding
for their reusable sustainable period
underwear and they were you guessed it
turned down period shaming period
poverty
period waste funding sexism pinky gate
got a lot of people
noticing these long time issues for
women
normalizing the natural is an ongoing
battle
and in germany it seems like the gloves
have come off
you